[Music]
the number of ways that you can think
about black holes but one nice way in to
the subject is to think about something
that's much more familiar thinking about
escape velocity let me describe what I
mean through a couple of sequences here
so imagine that you are on the surface
of the earth so let's sort of zoom down
right to our planet and we ask ourselves
if we fire a projectile from the surface
of the earth upward what will happen and
we all pretty much know what will happen
right so if we take a cannon and we fire
a cannonball at a fairly modest speed
it's going to go up it's going to come
back down if we fire it with a somewhat
larger speed it'll go up higher but
still it'll come back down but finally
if we launch it with the right speed it
will go up and it will just barely
escape the gravitational pull of the
earth and it will go off into space and
that speed required for that to happen
is what we call escape velocity at the
surface of the earth now what is the
escape velocity at the surface of the
earth yeah if someone actually said it
was 11.2 km/s thank you Wow the gold
star in the back there about 11
kilometers per second is what you need
to surface the earth but here's the
question if you were to look at a
different planet well that's bigger than
the earth what will happen well again
you can pretty much picture what will
happen if it's bigger it's more massive
you're going to need a bigger cannon to
fire that cannonball with higher speed
because the escape velocity will go up
it'll be larger than it is at the
surface of the earth but of course if
you have that big cannon you actually
fire it the cannonball will go up and
again if its speed is bigger than escape
velocity
it will be able to get away but now I
want you to think about something a
little bit less familiar imagine that
this cannon is not firing cannon balls
but it's firing balls of light
photons now light goes really quickly
right I mean light speed what does the
speed of light above is everybody uses
different units which is nice 671
million miles per hour 300 million
comments per second right meters per
second I should say so at that high
speed of course light will easily be
able to escape and be able to go off
into space but here's the interesting
thought experiment and this is a thought
experiment that goes way back this was
an experiment that this fella over here
John Mitchell this is in the 1700s right
long time ago he asked the following
question he said look what if you were
to imagine looking at say a star like
the Sun now clearly the escape velocity
at the surface of the Sun is much less
than the speed of light so certainly all
the light that the Sun emits easily gets
away but just as the escape velocity of
a planet goes up if you make it bigger
more massive he asked well the same
should happen for a star so let's
imagine making the star bigger where the
escape velocity goes up now if it's
still less than the speed of light the
light will get away but he asked what
would happen if you made the star so big
that the escape velocity at its surface
would be bigger than the speed of light
right in that case he imagined that if
you made that gigantically massive star
light could not get away the escape
velocity would be bigger than the speed
of light and if light doesn't get away
the star would go dark a dark star now
this is again in the 1700s right so he
is thinking purely in a Newtonian
framework that's the only description of
gravity that we had back then so the
natural question is is this musing of
John Michell right to steal loads and
this natural philosopher from the 18th
century does this idea have relevance
when you start to think about gravity
in the manner that was given to us by
this fellow over here Albert Einstein
because I think as we all know in the
early years of the 20th century Einstein
rethought our understanding of gravity
and he gave us the general theory of
relativity in which gravity is now
thought of in a completely new way not
the Newtonian description gravity is
thought of as warps and curves in the
fabric of space and time so Einstein
takes this idea this new way of thinking
about gravity he writes his famous paper
on the general theory of relativity this
is in 1915 his paper becomes widely
circulated and indeed about a year later
1916 on the Russian front there's a
German astronomer mathematician named
Karl Schwarzschild and he's out there in
the trenches charged with calculating
artillery trajectories and somehow just
by coincidence what happens is Einsteins
paper just kind of goes by he grabs a
hold of it and he gets so captivated by
Einsteins ideas that he forgets about
artillery trajectories and starts to
calculate with general relativity he
finds that if you have a spherical body
that you crush down to a very small size
according to Einstein's math the warp in
the fabric of space would be so extreme
that nothing can pull away not even
light can pull away so it's now a modern
day version if you will of what John
Michell had imagined an object that goes
black because light cannot pull away
from it so roughly speaking it would be
as if you had a flashlight near the edge
of one of these objects and when you
turn on the light instead of a light
going off into space like it's pulled
down into the hole into the black hole
this is the modern-day version of what a
black hole would be now the term black
hole it turned out this was coined on
112 Street and Broadway
I'm not joking at the Goddard Institute
of Space Studies on 112th and Broadway
John Wheeler was given a talk and this
way of describing these dark stars came
up and wheeler pushed this idea he
popularized to say he advanced our
understanding of it but this is where
the term black hole comes from now this
of course is a sort of cartoon version
that gets at the basic idea for those
that want to see it a little bit more
precisely here's really what goes on
near the vicinity of a black hole and if
you don't understand this it doesn't
matter we can put down a spacetime
diagram if you remember from high school
this is where we have time on this
vertical axis and you set off a beam of
light that fills out a cone so-called
light cone and what happens is the
geometry of space and time is so
distorted by a black hole that beyond
what's called the event horizon the
direction of time and space is so
twisted that as light propagates it
cannot get out of the edge it cannot go
beyond the event horizon of the black
hole and that's why no light can get out
that's why the black hole is black now
natural question is okay these are
interesting ideas but how in the world
would one of these objects come to be
and people began to think about this
idea for a long time 30s 40s 50s and let
me give you one possible scenario by
which the kind of object we're looking
at a black hole would form and for that
we can imagine that we have a large star
like a red giant to support its
incredible weight this star has nuclear
processes taking place in the core that
generate heat and light and pressure
that props the star up but sooner or
later the star uses up all of its
nuclear fuel and at that point they
can't support its own weight so it
begins to implode and as it implodes it
gets hotter and denser finally setting
off an explosion that ripple
through the star and when the explosion
reaches the surface of the star it
causes the outer layers to explode and
what remains if the star was big enough
to begin with is a tiny core a dense
core that can no longer support its own
weight at all and it will collapse all
the way down into one of these objects
these black holes that's the idea of how
these objects could form and what we'd
like to do here tonight is explore our
current thinking about these objects are
they real how would we actually see them
and can we get any insight into what
happens inside of these spectacular
objects and to do that we are going to
bring out some experts who spent their
careers examining these very questions
and let's get to them right now so our
first guest is one of the world's
leading experts in observational
astrophysics who heads UCLA's galactic
center group best known for a
groundbreaking insights on the center of
our galaxy this is the winner of among
other things the Crawford Prize in
astronomy from the Royal Swedish Academy
of Science Anna MacArthur Fellow
please welcome Andre agos
all right also joining us is an
astronomer at the harvard-smithsonian
Center for Astrophysics who leads an
international collaborative project
called the event horizon telescope whose
goal is to image the edge the event
horizon of a black hole so please
welcome Shep dollar mark for joining us
here tonight let me just begin with sort
of one general question so people have
been thinking about this idea of black
holes for a long time as I said all the
way back in the 1700s and a lot of
research has been done thousands of
pages of calculations do you think that
there are really black holes out there
or our theorist imaginations overworked
I think it's pretty clear that there are
black holes out there of course I'm a
little biased since you spend your life
trying to observe them yes that's it the
fact that there are two kinds of black
holes yes black holes that you were just
talking about the ones that come from
the lifespan of stars and then the
supermassive black holes that we think
are at the center of the galaxy and
those are the ones that you've actually
been studying in some detail so that
we're going to get to those in just a
moment but Shep your general view is
more or less the same or do you think
there's a chance that it's a red herring
that these black things are not really
out there oh no it's a beyond a shadow
of a doubt I really think they exist I
mean there's all these lines of evidence
and we see these terrifying engines that
the Centers of galaxies that spew out
these Jets on either side of them and
the only thing that can power them are
supermassive black holes so everything
is pointing to the fact that these
really do exist good so I'm glad you're
saying that because had you both said no
I don't know what we do with the rest of
our time here today but that's great so
so Andreea your work as I understand it
has been focused on the center of the
Milky Way galaxy so first of all just
just give us some sense of what you
think is residing in the center of our
galaxy and then we'll try to look at the
evidence that led you to come to that
conclusion so we are pretty convinced
that there's a supermassive black hole
at the center of our galaxy and
Oh Superman well when we say
supermassive we mean a million - uh well
in the case of our own galaxy 4 million
times the mass of the Sun and in terms
of these really big ones that are at the
center of galaxies that's on the low end
because we think about things that are a
million to a billion times the mass of
the Sun and and for a million solar mass
black hole like how like for the Sun
let's maybe start simple if the Sun was
turned into a black hole
how what would its radius be it would be
about the size of college campus
no it depends which college we're
talking about good so so a couple
kilometers across for the one in the
center of the galaxy how big do we think
it is it's about ten times the size of
the Sun so about ten million ten million
kilometers Wow so it's it's it's a big
object but it still follows the same
basic pattern that it has an edge and
event horizon and all the standard lore
would apply to it it's just on a bigger
scale right it just scales simply with
math yeah so so so what evidence do you
have that it is a black hole can you
sort of take us through that yeah so to
prove that there's a black hole directly
what you want to do is you want to you
want to show that there's a lot of mass
inside a small volume or inside a small
region and particularly you'd like to
show that it's confined within its short
shield radius that you were just talking
to the latest is is the radius for a
given mass where if you can crush the
mass within that radius it will
naturally turn into a black hole right
and so that's what we're the size that
we're talking about because of course
the black hole itself is infinitesimally
small so this this isn't that the
abstract size and so our job just
clarify that so when you say that you're
talking about when the black hole forms
the matter crushes down to a small size
yeah so the idea of the Schwarzschild
radius or is that no light can escape it
as we were just talking about but it's
also true that once you get the mass to
scale gravity will overcome all other
known forces and there's nothing that
can stop the collapse of the object so
from a scientific point of view once
you've shown that a mass is within its
Schwarzschild radius you have come up
with for the proof of a black hole so
from the point of view of somebody who's
hunting for black holes your job is to
show that there's some amount of mass
inside of a small volume so the way
we've approached it at the center of the
galaxy is to look for the stars that are
at the heart of the galaxy and to
develop techniques that allow us to not
only see the stars that are that close
but that allow us to observe how they go
around the center so if you want to find
the center of the galaxy you can look up
in the night sky and find the
constellation of Sagittarius it's the
teapot and the teapot pours into the
center of the galaxy all right that's
your road so convenient and if you look
up at the night sky not in of course New
York but in a place that you can
actually see the night sky you can see
the Milky Way and the Milky Way is that
band of white light that comes from the
stars but there's also a lack of light
which is from all the dust so you can't
actually see the center of the galaxy at
wavelengths at your eye detects
so a key to the work that we've done is
to use infrared technology so looking at
light that is just long word of what
your eye detects maybe we're a TV remote
control works yep and that allows us to
see the stars that are at the center of
the galaxy and we'll have you found and
we've found that they go one that we can
see them which is rather amazing and
that they go around the center of the
galaxy quite fast so those my favorite
star in the galaxy
it's name is so2 goes around every same
again
so2 okay probably needs a better name
yeah it's real catchy but you can use
actually Newton's laws of physics to
show that if you go around every 16
years
and you measure the size of the orbit
which is about the size of our solar
system that shows that there's about
four million times the mass of the Sun
inside this incredibly small region and
and to give you a sense of the change of
our knowledge over our understanding of
what resides at the center of the galaxy
we've increased the density of dark
matter by a factor of ten million
compared to what was known before our
work so in a sense we've we've advanced
the case for the existence of
supermassive black holes by that amount
may think about anything in your life
that you'd like more of and being able
to get 10 million times more of right
and that's what's happened at the center
right so the basic argument as I
understand it is you're tracking these
stars and their motion can only be
explained if there is a black hole of
that mass residing in the center of the
galaxy you're basically weighing this
what's at the center there was this
actual data this is the real thing so
we've looked at two versions of it one
is the flat version which was show uh
was playing just a moment ago and and it
showed my favorite star and this is
actually a bigger view of the data that
we that we've taken over the last and I
can't believe I'm saying this 25 years
have you been involved with it since the
beginning this is my baby
it is so in fact it's it's interesting
to reflect back because when I first
proposed this experiment when I first
got my job at UCLA I thought I had a
good idea it was actually turned down
they said the technique wouldn't work
and even if it did we wouldn't see stars
and even if we saw stars we wouldn't see
them move so it was a lot of no no no's
right and in fact we were asking to do a
project that was only three years long
just to see that stars were moving fast
no one anticipated that they were moving
they would move so fast how fast is fast
just to give it oh oh like three million
miles an hour so they're they're hauling
and it's and it's rather remarkable that
we can measure something on a human time
scale and so as this project has gone on
and maybe we can talk a little later
about
you know what it takes the technology
has changed so much that it's enabled us
to do more and more sophisticated kinds
of work so this three dimensional
animation actually shows the kinds of
stars that we see at the center of the
galaxy and almost every single
prediction for what we should see near
the black hole is inconsistent with the
observations what does that mean that
means it's job security you're trying to
figure it out yeah but but it's not
inconsistent yet with say the general
relativistic prediction no so there's
both the physics side of this work where
you're trying to ask physics questions
like do supermassive black holes exist
how does gravity work near a
supermassive black hole
so the where we are today is that we can
definitive or at least in my opinion we
can definitively say that the
supermassive black hole exists and then
the where we are actually we are so in
the middle of this can we test
Einstein's theory of general relativity
and that is what your you're doing now
if I understand like we're in actually a
special time at this very moment right
yes we're in such a special moment I
can't believe I'm actually sitting here
as opposed to being in Hawaii thank you
for taking the time with but tell us
tell us what's going on so the reason
I'm so excited and we've been preparing
for this for years so you know we've
been doing wait there's no chance you're
gonna miss like this special moment by
officially I have grad students so we've
been using the Keck telescopes which are
pictured here for 25 years and watching
the star that goes around every 16 years
and if you want to test
Einstein's theory of general relativity
near supermassive black hole with these
stars what you have to do is first make
your first go around that gives you a
baseline of what what part of space
these stars are probing and that's 16
years right there that's 16 years right
there my various moments in my life are
at the star and then what you want to do
is you want to catch it the next time
it goes through closest approach and
that next time was the year 2018
so I've been thinking 2018 or bust for a
number of years so we're in it we're in
this season and for us there really is a
season
because the earth goes around the Sun so
and because we're looking at infrared
light you're gonna hear from Shep there
are different kinds of vices Shep
doesn't care about this because the
earth goes around the Sun there's only a
part of the year that we can see the
center of the galaxy at infrared
wavelengths so for me we can see it from
roughly March to roughly October so
there was the beginning of the season
and through these roughly six months
this star is experiencing incredible
accelerations and is experiencing the
most extreme forms of gravity as it
makes its closest approach so actually
there are three key moments one that
happened April 10th that happened
roughly last week and one that's
happening in September that are going to
nail down this experiment so it is it's
an exciting moment for us and to see the
signal emerge from the data it's it's
just a treat so if I understand
correctly have a prediction based on the
general theory of relativity what the
trajectory should be well here we have
to be a little bit careful because
there's a series of kinds of experiments
that you part me there's a series of
tests of gravity one is how the the
light from the star makes it from the
star to us in other words how it escapes
the curvature of space-time that's
actually the first thing that we're
getting at this summer the next thing is
then how the object itself moves through
space-time which is actually should
emerge over the next few years so again
and if you keep going and of course
that's what we want to do you can
actually measure the spin of the black
hole so this experiment just keeps
getting better right and and it's
particularly interesting I gather
because you know most people think that
Einstein's
general relativity has been confirmed
but is that the right way of thinking
about it well it's uh you know it's one
of the fun gravity is one of the four
fundamental forces but oddly enough it's
the least tested of those forces so it's
been tested in some regimes but it's
never been tested near a supermassive
black hole and in some sense a
supermassive black hole or black holes
in generals represent the breakdown of
this theory so what you want to do is
you want to get as close as possible to
the Hat point where you actually know
that theory is no longer holding up and
I think we have to have today all sorts
of pieces of evidence that says this
theory is fraying at the edges so we
just push that frontier forward by a
large amount in a direction that hasn't
been explored before so in principle you
could find the first concrete evidence
that we need to go beyond Einsteins
ideas to really describe what's going on
I mean the best of all worlds
that would be the outcome of 16 plus
years of observation well the outcome is
actually just figuring out what's really
happening you're the black hole whatever
it is yeah yeah yeah spectacular so chef
you you were also in the business of
looking at black holes there's no
business like black hole biz no business
like back over there and so you're going
about in a different way so we're
hearing about infrared light as the
probe being used to in andreas work
you're using what radio yeah we're using
radio waves it turns out that black
holes in a paradox of their own gravity
are some of the brightest things in the
sky right and that's because of a very
simple construct all the mat all the gas
and dust is trying to get into a very
small region so it heats up to hundreds
of billions of degrees around
Sagittarius a star the supermassive
black hole in the center of our galaxy
and it radiates in infrared that andraia
looks at and also radio waves even
little bit in x-rays so if you want to
look at a black hole you can come at it
from many many different angles no no
critical to both of what you're saying
is you're not really looking at the
black hole you're looking at its effect
on its environment right so you can't
actually see it person
exactly what happens in the black hole
stays in the black yeah let's just get
that out of the way right now but what
we do is we tease around the edges right
so in that cannonball analogy you had
before light was leaving the black hole
but it also orbits around the black hole
just think about that for a minute light
orbits something right and goes around
in a circle and Einstein 100 years ago
when he came up with this general theory
of relativity those equations show that
you should see the silhouette of light
around the black hole and that's because
of these light orbits around so we look
at it and you see light moving around
the black hole and it gets brighter on
one side on the other side you see
something that should be about five
times the swirl radii across you know
how how big it should be so the event
horizon is here and you're looking at
five times that distance yeah exactly so
you never see inside the black hole you
see outside and that shows us the
geometry of space-time when you see
something like this when you see this
shadow feature you're really looking at
the deepest puncture in space-time that
we can imagine right and the question
it's actual have you is this what you
guys I mean can you share with us what
you guys have seen this is the event
horizon telescope I gather you're
talking right so there so the question
is if you wanted to zoom in by orders of
many many thousands and see what was
happening right the edge of a black hole
you'd have to go way beyond where
aundrea sees her stars and go much
closer and those stars are about a
thousand times farther out than this
silhouette that you're seeing here right
and if we could measure the size of the
silhouette in the shape we test
Einstein's theory of gravity right at
the edge of the black hole right now how
are you doing that yeah there is a
handful of radio telescopes I gather
yeah so to see something this small
these are the smallest objects in the
known universe right black holes are
tiny and to see them you need magnifying
power and as it is with all telescopes
the bigger the telescope the more
magnifying power you have now we can't
make a one huge telescope that sees
radio waves what we do is we install
atomic clocks had multiple radio dishes
around the world we record data and then
we play it back at a central facility
and we create a virtual telescope as big
as the earth ourselves these are some of
the people who who
on these various places how many teams
are there well we have eight geographic
locations right now and we're going to
nine and then ten the year after next
and when you stitch together all of
these telescopes you wind up getting a
virtual dish that's the size of the
earth that is exactly tuned it turns out
to image the supermassive black hole in
the center of our galaxy and we've just
taken some of the first data from this
event horizon telescope one year ago and
we're crunching on the data now and what
have you what have you found
I can't tell you oh come on no it turns
out that if you if you really want to
make one of these images it takes a long
time to calibrate the data it's all
about the details a lot of people think
that we just turn this telescope on and
we'll see something immediately but it's
you know we're nerds at heart and we
just love to get to the telescopes and
find all these details and it turns out
that you really have to run down every
single one of these possible sources of
contamination the data before you can be
sure that you've seen this kind of
shadow silhouette yeah you know we were
able to actually talk to a couple
members of the of the team who slipped
us actually some of the data I hope you
don't mind if we if we show it here to
show the chubbie this is actually I'm
understanding this is the the most
precise image ever of a black hole
do we have that can we bring the lights
down and show this is that is that
doable
yeah so so yeah all right there there
there it is very good yeah so that's
good enough for us thank you
no oh um so uh you can look the real
nervous there for a second yeah so so
when will you be releasing I saw an
article just a couple of days ago which
is kind of a teaser it seemed like for a
release of data that's coming up is that
soon and it'll probably be in the first
part of the 2019 2019 yeah
because right now we're crunching the
data you know we know that the event
horizon telescope worked so what we did
was we also looked at quasars
supermassive black holes that are really
far away where basically point sources
and everything seems to have worked
perfect
technically on the telescope so so we
know that all the systems are a go and
then we turned all the telescope swivel
to look at Sagittarius a star the
supermassive black hole in the center of
our galaxy and and we think everything
is working fine there but we're still
crunching on the data so and and the
data I saw some article that had come
from the South Pole and you had to wait
for the the winter to clear to fly that
was that the kind of yeah that's going
on or well so that the whole point as
Andrea said if you want to test
Einstein's theory you've got to go to
the most extreme points in the universe
you've got to go to the ultimate proving
ground which is the edge of a black hole
and we have to go to some pretty extreme
places ourselves right so we have teams
that go down to the South Pole we go to
the tops of extinct volcanoes where
there are radio dishes that do the work
that we want to do we go to Hawaii Mauna
Kea high desert plains and Chile and you
go up to these sites and it's really a
bit of a labor of love because all these
teams go there they work their hearts
out they capture data in this technique
that we use this event horizon telescope
technique is really the ultimate and
delayed gratification alright because
here's what you do it so what when Andre
goes to our telescope it's pretty
straightforward from conceptually the
light bounces off a paraboloid it goes
to the focus that's it right you get
what you want right there what happens
with us is the light hits one of our
dishes it's stored through high speed
instrumentation that we've built over
the last decade on hard disks the same
kind of hard disk that you would get in
your computer and they stay there until
they're brought back on an airplane
because nothing beats the bandwidth of a
747 filled with distress nothing okay
even when I'm walking down the hallway
with two of these disks you know I'm
beating the fastest internet in the
world okay and we bring them back
together and the operation in this
supercomputer that we use is equivalent
to light bouncing off of a perfectly
shaped parabola joining in coherence
alright so we play it back together and
we adjust it back and forth until we get
it just right and that effectively turns
the earth into a parabola if you think
about that so all of this data has to
come back and if it's at the South Pole
it's in a deep freeze right so we've got
to wait six months just to get that data
back right all right so that's more of
the delay
that we've been faced not you now you
have done some simulations of what you
anticipate emerging from the data
looking at the magnetic field and
vicinity of a black hole can you take us
through some of the things that you
anticipate emerging from the study I
think we have some things up sure so
what you're seeing here is the best
guess we have from your high speed
simulations of what you would see if you
had infinite resolution goggles right so
you wind up seeing this this shadow
feature the circular feature with some
Jets leaving from the North and South
Poles and that's because there are
magnetic fields right around the
boundary of the black hole there's
relativistic particles they're orbiting
in these magnetic fields and they're
releasing something called synchrotron
emission which is kind of a
characteristic radio emission you get
from these kinds of sources and it's so
bright in that synchrotron emission that
it shines out from the deepest part of
the gravity well right so you so think
about it everything has to go right it's
a Goldilocks situation you have to be
able to see through the Earth's
atmosphere and radio waves can do that
you've got to be able to see through the
distance between the earth and the
galactic center radio waves can
summarize that just to give people a
sense it so it's about 25,000
light-years away good right so it's you
know this black hole is not threatening
to us we observe it it's nice
so these radio waves can go all the way
to the you know from the black hole but
then we're not done yet because it has
to go through the hot gas swirling
around the black hole right and then it
has to go all the way down into the
gravity well so it's a Goldilocks
situation because we meet all those
criterion with radio waves and it turns
out that the earth happens to be just
the right size so that when you look at
radio waves with a wavelength of 1
millimeter they're perfectly tuned to
take the picture of Sagittarius a star
that's it with an earth-sized dish it
was just resolution yeah so sometimes
nature throws us all these curveballs
you know we can't do this or this is
hard this is one case where everything's
falling into place and so we really
think we have a good shot of taking a
the first image of a black hole and and
do you have a chance as well of finding
a deviation from the
general theory of relativity can this be
viewed as another extreme testing ground
well we're looking it's never a good
idea to bet against Einstein okay
I don't make it a point in my career to
do it you know but it is a trust but
verify situation okay I mean he's a he
was a very smart guy
let's put it that way but every theory
needs to be tested well when you say
he's a very smart guy that's true but he
wasn't a great fan of this idea of black
holes at all right I mean he kind of
didn't think they were real well well
this is how he was a little bit off on
that one right okay so he had one bad
moment but but this really speaks to
this kind of golden age that Dandrea was
talking about with the event horizon
telescope where the observations are
being made by the CAC we're really in
this discovery space for black holes and
we could be at the moment when we can
start to answer these questions like do
black holes exist was Einstein right at
the very black hole boundary I mean you
know you showed shorts child in the
trenches in World War one yeah you know
and he died later that year actually so
this was his last big discovery and he
wrote down the Schwarzschild metric and
he gave what to take my space outside of
black the shape of space outside the
black hole and and now we're kind of
engaging in this handshake across 100
years where we're kind of completing
this circuit and we're saying you know
you made these intense predictions and
we're just at the point now where we
might be able to test them right and
that is extraordinary and and it speaks
to the fact that science is not linear
we don't go from point A to point B we
don't say we're gonna march and test
this it's very erratic and and that's
why Einstein felt black holes might not
exist it took a hundred years for them
to become part of our lexicon right
you're part of the reality of our
everyday conversation now do you do do
either of you or both of you as you're
working on your observational projects
do you have pet ideas or pet theories
about what the next phase beyond
Einstein might be or do you just
basically just go forward into the data
the observations and and that's the only
thing that's really driving you or do
have a an idea of what might be the next
phase of this understanding of gravity
well well let me just take this one
second I'm a real I'm a realist I'm kind
of a craftsman at heart like I like to
go to the tops of mountains and make
observations I like to see what's around
the black hole right I can understand
and wrap my brain around the light
that's coming outside the event horizon
what's inside the event horizon you know
that's a question that is hard to even
ask you know let alone just asked it I
did it's harder to answer it I did it's
easy to wonder at ya know but but but
for example one thing we're looking at
with the event horizon telescope is to
see if that silhouette is not round
ah what if it's distorted okay and if
it's distorted then we have some
framework of understanding how general
relativity itself might be violated to
give us those strange shapes so we're
betting on Einstein we're betting it's
gonna be circular but if it's not we
have some ways of understanding what
might make it non circular yep so we're
winding down to the end of our section
about Andre I wanted to ask you a
question which is how do you proceed in
an era when you might be going beyond
Einstein when do you know that you're
right when when do you know that things
have coalesced to the point that you're
willing to make a statement of that sort
interesting and important question that
we're really in the thick of because if
you see things that don't make sense you
you don't have a context you're you're
kind of extend you're exposed and you
have to convince yourself that what
you're seeing is physics as opposed to
experimental error right err err err so
I I think there's a an interesting
philosophical point here about how do
you convince yourself you've got the
right answer yeah I mean there was an
interesting case with bicep2
oh yes a few years ago where some have
said that they so knew what they were
looking for that they were biased in
assessing
what the data was telling them it's a
classic thing called confirmation bias
so and this kind of work where we have
such a respect for Einstein and his
ideas that we go in with a premise that
it must be correct so it is interesting
in terms of how you actually design your
team's work to avoid getting a result
you believe to be true and allowing your
team to really trust what the data is
telling you so I think that's a that
that's certainly my goal as a scientist
to get to that point where you're really
just listening or paying attention to
the information that might be unexpected
but to try to remove your your desire to
have any particular answer be it
Einstein right or be it Einstein wrong
yep just to be open to whatever the
answer truly is right yeah well I should
say you know all of us revere Einstein
but at the same time how thrilling would
be if either or both you find evidence
that we do need to go beyond the
insights that he gave us a hundred years
ago so we wish you well and we'll have
you back a year or two maybe then you'll
be able to give us some insight into
what you guys have found so everybody
please join me in thanking our great
guys Jeff : oh thank you very much
you
[Music]